[Music]
in a perfect world relationships would
be as easy as pie but evidently they're
a little more complicated than that
this couldn't be more true for the
handful of Disney stars who ended up
dating Nickelodeon actors watch until
the end to find out which star-crossed
lovers are still an item today first
time with the things don't forget to hit
that subscribe button and give this
video a big thumbs up now let's find out
which Disney stars fell in love with
their on-screen competitors Emily Osment
and Tony Oller there are a few Disney
stars as successful as Emily Osmond
which is why we just can't get enough of
her she wowed us with her hilarious
facial expressions on the hit Disney
Channel show Hannah Montana and she
continues to do so today while we knew
that Osmond wouldn't stay single for too
long we were shocked to find out that
she'd taken a liking to Tony Oller a
Nickelodeon child star tony is known for
playing the role of Walt Moore on the
popular TV series gigantic although the
couple seemed to be a match made in
heaven it didn't take long for them to
realize that their differences
outweighed their similarities before
long the young couple decided to call it
quits and let's just say that their fans
weren't too happy about the news Emily
and Tony dated for a total of 7 months
and ended their relationship back in
2010 while it's easy to forget about
this Odd Couple
we're not ready to sweep their love
under the rug just yet while it's pretty
clear that these two have no interest in
getting back together we're just happy
that they gave each other at the time of
day
Victoria justice and Cole Sprouse it
goes without saying that celebrities
want to keep their relationship secret
after all no one wants to have their
personal life broadcasted for all to see
regardless of this it's common for
celebs to be in the spotlight at all
times of the day whether they like it or
not by now we all know who Cole Sprouse
is the child actor grew up in front of
the camera and reached the international
success by playing the role of Cody
Martin on Disney Channel's The Suite
Life of Zack and Cody
today he's known for acting the part of
Jughead Downes on the TV series
Riverdale although he might be
his on-screen girlfriends Lily Reinhart
he didn't always stay people from the
same production as him believe it or not
but Sprouse is rumored to have dated
Nickelodeon star victoria justice back
in the day although this couple kept
their relationship top secrets they were
ousted by fellow Disney star Alyson
Stoner who claims as Sprouse and justice
hunted thing way back when
while we're shocked to hear about this
pairing we can't help but think that
they make a gorgeous couple nevertheless
many of us are happy that these two
didn't work out because in the end we
love ourselves some Jughead and Betty
Miley Cyrus and admin Joe Joe isn't
young love a beautiful thing while we
think so
with this in mind many of us couldn't
believe our eyes when Disney star Miley
Cyrus and Nickelodeon sensation Avan
Jogia
were spotted canoodling back in 2010
their relationship might have been short
but it did cause an uproar after all it
isn't every day that a Disney and
Nickelodeon star decide to cross
networks and date back when Miley was
living a double life on Disney's Hannah
Montana Avenue was stealing the
spotlight on Victorious the pair
eventually decided to make their
relationship public and received going
on dates in Hollywood while they made
this super cute couple
Miley has always had her eyes on someone
else she and actor Liam Hemsworth have
been engaged since 2016 and they're
clearly in it for the long haul while
most people would be sad to have loved
and loved someone as wonderful as Miley
Cyrus Aven seems to have moved on just
fine as a matter of fact some of us
might even go as far as calling him a
serial dater
were you aware of these network cross
lovers or is this all news to you
Veronica Dunne and Max Eric Veronica
Dunn is an American actress who is known
for playing Marissa Clark on the popular
Disney show Casey Undercover the
gorgeous celebrity has been in the
spotlight since she was a preteen which
is where she met and fell in love with
Nickelodeon actor max Eric while max is
primarily known for being a reoccurring
Nickelodeon star he's managed to
transcend networks on more than one
account not only did he date Veronica
for over three years but he also joined
the Disney Channel to take part in
movies like High School Musical scene
year Veronica and Max seem to be the
perfect match but after a long
relationship the couple chose to go
their separate ways
max took to Twitter to confirm their
separation back in July of 2017 the
melodramatic actor tweeted that he was
single which caused his fans a whole lot
of grief in the end we never saw this
breakup coming especially since the
young couple seemed to be
head-over-heels for each other whether
they were singing duets on the beach or
posting cute selfies on social media it
was pretty clear that they were in it to
win it
although the split came as a shock to
the public Veronica and Max assured
their fans that they sincerely respect
each other
but no longer want to be in a
relationship we don't know about you but
this Disney Nickelodeon breakup was
definitely a hard one for us to accept
but hey we never know what the future
holds Victoria Justice and Pearson foud
when it comes down to it it's pretty
obvious that Victoria Justice has a
thing for Disney Channel stars after all
she's been rumored to have had
relationships with a handful of them
although justice might have dated Cole
Sprouse for an undetermined amount of
time she ended up falling for her
on-screen partner Pearson foud while
filming Naomi and Ely's no-kiss list
foud is one of the few actors who has
managed to work for both Nickelodeon and
Disney we'll never do the things that
you did although he spent most of his
time jumping between networks he did
have a reoccurring role on the hit
Disney TV series Jessie after meeting
and immediately heading it off back in
2013 Victoria and Pearson decided to
make things official they did their best
to keep their love life on the down-low
after dating for two years the couple
decided to go in a break for a couple of
months however this was back in 2015 and
the ex-lovers have yet to get back
together in the end it appears that they
made the right choice but that doesn't
make it any easier
despite their separation justice and
bode remained good friends who respect
and care for one another well it would
appear as though young love isn't made
to last the last couple on this list
will prove this theory wrong Audrey
would be and Joey Bragg there's a lot
more to Audrey would be than meets the
eye and this is something that Joey
bragging those all to well the young
celebrity knew that she wanted to be an
actress
from early on which prompted her to
pursue dozens of productions before long
Audrey secured roles on both the Disney
Channel and Nickelodeon coincidentally
the same can be said about Joey Bragg
who would eventually meet his future
girlfriend on the set of awesomeness TV
just puttin it out there according to
Joey he first laid eyes on Audrey when
they were paired up to act out a sketch
for the hilarious TV show Joey who was
only clad in his tighty whities approach
to wit thee while wearing a parachute
cape around his neck at this point he
looked her right in the eyes and told
her that his name is Joey and this is
what most of his body looks like
evidently Audrey couldn't resist his
charm and humor causing the pair to hit
it off immediately from then on these
two actors have made love look
effortless congratulations guys you're
one of the few Disney Nickelodeon
couples to make it to the end but
hopefully you won't be the last
Vanessa Hudgens and Austin Butler there
are a few things worse than finding out
that your favorite celebrity couple has
chosen to end their relationship this
news can come as a shock especially when
these couples seem to have the perfect
lives more often than not however social
media can be deceiving
while famous couples might seem
head-over-heels for each other online
this isn't always the case when the
cameras are off although it's been over
eight years since Vanessa Hudgens and
Zac Efron broke up many of us still view
them as the best Disney Channel couple
of all time in fact after they announced
their split we were sure that they'd be
back together in no time unfortunately
for us High School Musical fans this
wasn't the case instead Hudgens went on
to date a Nickelodeon star named Austin
Butler Butler had a few minor roles in
Nickelodeon TV series like zoey 101 but
they were enough to catch Hodgins eyes
today Hudgens and Butler have been
happily dating for over seven years and
they seemed to be as happy as can be
despite being from different networks
these two stars did everything they
could to make their relationship last
and well they did a fantastic job so are
you team Efron or Butler let us know in
the comments Emma Roberts and Evan
Peters
Emma Roberts and Evan Peters aren't the
typical everyday couple although they
appeared to love each other with every
fiber of their being they tend to be a
little destructive in times of conflict
say what you will about the couple but
there isn't a doubt in our minds that
they belong together when Roberts was in
the market for her first ever TV role
she came across the Nickelodeon TV show
unfabulous at around the same time
Peter's got cast as Phil's best friend
Seth on the hit Disney Channel show Phil
of the future although the pair never
met while working for these networks
they eventually did on the set of adult
world in 2012 before long Robertson
Peters decided to make their
relationship public because let's face
it their chemistry was undeniable
despite there being a lot of love in
their relationship there was also a lot
of drama so much so that the couple is
notorious for breaking up and getting
back together their intense relationship
has never stopped them from working
together however which is why they can
both be found on the set of American
Horror Story for the time being it
appears as though the fiery couple is
back together but there's no way of
knowing for sure if there's one thing we
do know though is that this couple plays
hard and loves hard after two great
splits and one broken engagement we're
led to believe that these two lovers
will never stop navigating through
stormy waters but hey as long as they're
cool with it so are we Paris Pharrell's
and Jack Griffo and now the moment
you've been waiting for the cross
network couple of the year is none other
than Paris Burrell's and Jack Griffo
these two actors aren't shy when it
comes to expressing their feelings on
social media in fact they're so
Instagram savvy that many of their fans
have deemed them the perfect couple
despite starting his acting career with
Disney Jack eventually joined forces
with the Nickelodeon network he's
praised for playing the role of max
Thunderman on the thundermans which he
has been doing for the last five years
Paris on the other hand has mostly
remained faithful to the Disney Channel
Network have a - cries a week maximum
well through in one day but she did make
it a point to cameo in her boyfriend's
Nickelodeon show which was totally
adorable for now it looks as though
being from different networks is the
least of their worries especially when
they've got a million things going for
them at once
in 2017 the couple traveled to Las Vegas
where they had a fake wedding
this stunt gave them tons of publicity
but left their fans with one simple
question they wanted to know when they
will get married for real for the time
being it looks as though Paris and Jack
don't have marriage on the brain but
it's just a matter of time before the
topic surfaces so which Disney
Nickelodeon couple was your favorite be
sure to tell us who and why in the
comments and that's it for our video
thanks for watching and see you next
time
on the things
[Music]